Mario is the most versatile character in
the Nintendo uvra but Kirby has to be a
close second though the pink puffball
may not spend his free time go-karting
or playing tennis his catalog includes a
ton of experimental games and art styles
that stretch the limits of what a Kirby
game can be Kirby's Return to Dreamland
Deluxe a remastered version of the 2011
Wii game for Nintendo switch is in most
ways a very traditional Kirby platformer
but it's playful spirit approachability
and a sizable new epilogue campaign make
it much more than a retread
[Music]
the main story component of Return to
Dreamland is a colorful romp as you
restore the parts of an alien ship set
to a joyful and buoyant soundtrack The
adorably bulbous alien magalore
crashlands on planet pop star and seeks
help from Kirby and his friends those
allies are a major component this time
because Dreamland features drop in Co-op
for up to four players you can include
any number of multi-colored kirbys in
your ranks but you can also bring along
other familiar faces Meta Knight bandana
waddle D and King Dedede each has their
own moveset Meta Knight is more agile
than the weighty DDD for example but
only Kirby has the signature copy
ability to swallow enemies Kirby's
combat isn't simplistic but it is
forgiving there's a ton of contextual
moves you can do with each copy ability
which means you can pull off some
impressive juggles but the enemies
aren't much of a threat so you don't
really need to master the combat it's a
different approach from some other
Nintendo franchises which use Simple
move sets to pull off an increasingly
difficult array of challenges this one
seems more aimed at letting players meet
it wherever they are within this simple
framework Return to Dreamland is
specially adapt at mixing different
types of challenges for a steady pace of
delightful surprise you'll often find
glowing enemies that Grant a Special
ultra version of your copy abilities
with screen filling effects
[Music]
holding on to these for a while will
usually open a hidden path or Grant you
a special item making it extra
worthwhile to play with their
over-the-top effects the variety is
especially on display when it comes to
occasional references to other games
like a power up that emulates kuribo's
shoe from Mario or a stage that treats
blast barrels like a stage from Donkey
Kong Country the cast of characters an
array of copy abilities along with
homages to Classic bosses like whispery
Woods make this feel like a greatest
hits collection but it does include a
pair of new copy abilities that long
time fans in particular are sure to
appreciate the sand ability is a cute
new addition giving Kirby a headdress
that looks like a waving Sandstorm and
replaces his main attack with swinging a
wave of sand at your enemies but it's
fairly similar to other existing copy
abilities that makes the other new
ability the mecca suit the real standout
when gobbling up robotic enemies Kirby
gets a power suit akin to a Gundam and
his suite of abilities ranges from a
long-range laser to arcing Rockets I
grabbed the mecca ability whenever I had
the option because it's just so
versatile and fun to play
this all might make Return to Dreamland
sound like a cakewalk but it would be
more accurate to say that it ramps up to
a comfortable difficulty even in its
hardest stages I would only die once or
twice which made the overall experience
Breezy rather than frustrating that
should make it ideal for any younger
players looking for a gentle on-ramp to
Nintendo's expertise in platforming
craftsmanship the co-op play also means
more experienced players or parents can
help guide younger players along but for
solo play Return to Dreamland Deluxe
features a new helper magalore feature
if you turn it on you'll get a handful
of helpful assists double stamina
immunity from falling deaths and a
toggled on option that automatically
activates Kirby's copy forms instead of
needing to trigger them manually all of
this has the net effect of making a
relatively easy game even easier but
it's a nice set of training wheels for
those who need them after you finish the
main story and extra mode opens up that
presents more challenging versions of
the same stages it's a nice touch but it
would have been better to offer the
option from the beginning rather than
Force more experienced players to go
through the story once just to earn the
ability to do it again but harder the
much more significant post story Edition
new to this deluxe version is an
epilogue story starring a disheveled
magalore as the playable character what
sets magalor apart from the rest of the
Kirby characters is his wide array of
magical abilities Each of which has
extensive upgrades these newly crafted
stages let you gather upgrade points to
make him stronger and there's a real
sense of progression as you discover new
abilities and then juice them up since
the stages are custom built for magalor
they feel like a real test of his own
unique movement and skills and special
challenge stages are locked to having
upgraded your abilities to a certain
skill level so that you can conquer them
the new stages also make use of visual
flourishes that I didn't notice in the
main game like a rainfall effect playing
as magalor feels very distinct from the
rest of the Kirby characters but
satisfying in its own way his floating
ability makes him very agile and since
he has access to his spells all the time
he's very capable in combat without
needing to find a copy ability first my
one gripe was with his Dash attack which
was mapped onto the standard attack
button when combined with running so it
would often trigger even when I didn't
mean it to rounding out the package is
Mary magoland a carnival-like attraction
with magalor as its ring Master letting
you take part in an array of mini-games
from across Kirby history along with two
new additions playing them earns you
stamps that fill up Punch Cards for
masks of familiar Kirby characters which
you can then wear into the regular
platformer stages plus progressing
through challenges in the mini games
helps you fill out the carnival setting
with statues and other decorative
elements this is the Delirious remnant
of return to dreamland's Origins on the
Wii right down to the Wiimote
functionality that has been mapped to
the switch joy-cons these games are fine
but only that there are a couple
standouts in the bunch like checkered
board Chase and booming blasters but
just as many Duds most of them are so
short that it doesn't feel inviting to
go through the menus just to play once
but they're also not engaging enough to
play repeatedly there is a magoland tour
feature that randomly mixes four mini
games together but there's no way to
pick a mix or to sort them by theme like
motion controlled games so it never
quite comes together Mary magoland is
so-so as a distraction and may appeal to
younger audiences but it's certainly not
the main attraction fortunately though
that main attraction is delightful
Kirby's Return to Dreamland Deluxe feels
like a very complete package thanks to a
remastered platformer campaign
substantial new magalore epilogue and
smart new additions like the Mecca
ability and helper magalore mode it
might be a little simple for some tastes
but it's Grand fun to get lost in such a
sweet little Adventure regardless
[Music]
okay